من خلال دعوة الرئيس التركي إلى
محادثات صفقة الحبوب في روسيا،
حصل فلاديمير بوتين على منصة كبيرة للتنفيس عن شكاواه
من الداعمين الغربيين لأوكرانيا،
الغرب، ليقول إنه خدعنا بشكل معتدل
بشأن الأهداف الإنسانية
لمبادرة البحر الأسود الإنسانية
لمساعدة البلدان النامية
ولكن قبل ساعات فقط.  خلال الاجتماع،
كانت طائرات بوتين بدون طيار تدمر
مخازن الحبوب الحيوية في أوكرانيا، كما
فعلت بكثافة متزايدة منذ
انسحاب روسيا من صفقة الحبوب في البحر الأسود
في يوليو/تموز،
وذهب أردوغان إلى سوتشي على أمل
إقناع بوتين بقبول صفقة الحبوب الجديدة للأمم المتحدة
إذا كان قد وافق على ذلك.  قد يكون النجاح بطيئًا
لأنني أعتقد أننا سنكون قادرين
على التوصل إلى حل يلبي
التوقعات قريبًا.
كانت الصفقة في الواقع صفقتين
متوازيتين، واحدة مع أوكرانيا، وواحدة مع
مفتشين روسيين يقومون بفحص الشحنات أثناء
خروج السفن الخضراء من البحر الأسود ودخلت
تركيا.  استمرت المياه لمدة عام
قبل أن يسحب بوتين من جانب واحد
أسباب خروجه من الصفقة التي تبدو
متجذرة في العقوبات الغربية المفروضة
نتيجة لحربه الاختيارية غير القانونية وغير المبررة التي
من المحتمل أن تستفيد الآن من
صفقة الحبوب لإلغاء بعض العقوبات.
ما رأيناه هو ذلك  كان هناك رفض
لتجديد عمليات تسليم
قطع الغيار الزراعية وكانت هناك أيضًا مشاكل
معهم، وكانت التسويات المالية ورسوم
المعاملات
تريد أن تكون صانعة للسلام ولكن في سوتشي
بدا أنها توبخ أوكرانيا وتضفي الشرعية على
جزيرة أوكرانيا لبوتين حتى
تتمكن من اتخاذ خطوات مشتركة  مع روسيا،
تحتاج أوكرانيا إلى تخفيف نهجها.
بوتين لا يوافق بحق إذا
ذهبت 44 من الحبوب إلى الدول الأوروبية.
يقول بوتين إنه سيفكر في إحياء
صفقة الحبوب التابعة للأمم المتحدة إذا حصل على ما يريد
والذي يتضمن إزالة ما
يدعي أنه قيود على التصدير  فيما يتعلق
بالمنتجات الزراعية الروسية، فإنه
يزيد أيضًا من الضغط
والضغط من خلال
صفقة حبوب بديلة منفصلة مع أردوغان
نيك روبرتسون سي إن إن لندن